*Sonnerie de iPhone*
C'est cool ça.
*Sonnerie version musique Metal*
*Sonnerie version musique Redneck*
*Sonnerie version musique Hip-Hop*
*Sonnerie version musique sinistre*
*Sonnerie version musique Electro*
*Sonnerie de iPhone*
Allô?
Ah merde.
Quoi?
C'est trop tard.
Ben si c'est important il rappellera.
Ouais.
Oui.
Ça doit être de la pub
ou un truc comme ça.
On les déteste ceux-là.
*Tonalité de téléphone*
Quel dommage.
Triple dommage pour
cet auditeur qui n'a pas décroché.
Car aujourd'hui, je vous le rappelle,
nous multiplions par 16
votre salaire pendant 32 ans.
En attendant, nous passons une belle après-midi
sur «Bonne chance FM».
*Sonnerie version musique Pop-Rock*
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo,
abonnez vous.
Et si vous préférez quand
on se fait trés mal, cliquez ici.
*Sonnerie de iPhone*
Ah ben décidément.
Tiens, c'est Carlito.
Allô ?
Euh ouais McFly.
Tu peux peut-être
me laisser en placer une ?
Ouais je t'en prie.
Alors retrouvez le FatShow,
(c'est une superbe émission),
sur EnormeTV, qui est
logiquement une chaîne de télévision.
Sinon j'aurais dis par exemple...
On a compris.
Je raccroche.
Je raccroche au nez.